you are somewhat probably familiar with
ideas of alien abductions and the
so-called typical being that's usually
involved in that is referred to as a
gray and they have been apparently
creating hybrid beings between
themselves and Earth humans they're
often shown the hybrid babies that are
created with their DNA mixing it with
the Grays and are told to relate to
those babies the one thing that's very
different about the way Bashar tells the
story is that the Grays are not alien
they're mutated humans from a parallel
Earth that destroyed itself and they
lost their ability to reproduce they
mutated into the form we now see them to
survive but in order for their race not
to die out they have used their advanced
technology to shift into parallel
realities like ours where humans are
still viable where they have taken DNA
to create hybrid beings that will
continue their
civilization